okay what year were you running around
with Suge Knight damn Shug probably like
young like
2008 nine yeah maybe 2007 even yeah yeah
yeah shook would give me a lot of game
man um you know and bring bring us
around and stuff and um
but you know I I seen the game change
and and you know I had to take a
different approach and um
you know you got to move with the times
you know what I'm saying how did you
guys initially connect who me and should
yeah well just you know just Compton
[__] you know what I'm saying so
um you know some of the big homies
um you know was [__] with him and you
know brought me around him and he took a
liking to me and are you making music at
this time uh I was but I was like you
know I'd kind of like
I'd gotten you know more caught up in
Street [__] I'm not gonna lie and like
music was just like second secondary to
me yeah it was like a hobby but
I um you know I definitely still did it
but it wasn't like you know what I'm
saying I was I didn't know really what
direction to go in yet you know what I'm
saying I didn't really have my sound
like before I started doing this stuff
is learning drugs
I'd put out one tape with mustard and um
I would just take different songs from
different Studios and I'm like mustard
was the homie so he hosted it yeah just
before he was making beats yeah this was
he was making BT it just did Rack City
okay so like and then Nema had hit me
that's how I got in the Empire system
because I remember I just threw the tape
out there this is still like like
physicals and like
um a couple of my boys that were uh from
like the jungles
um they were like instead of just
putting the tapes
um
and swap meets and liquor stores around
the hood you should go up to Fairfax and
put it in the hundreds in Supreme and
diamonds yeah yeah yeah so that kind of
like brought me up there and then
um you know people on that side of town
started hearing my [__] so I was like
you know I had the right intentions to
do it but I wasn't like it wasn't until
like you know I got with Sean and
started like you know really figuring
out my sound and what I wanted to do and
then um you know with the helper yeah it
was just kind of
showing me the ropes a little bit you
know yams did a lot he put me with Vice
and then that led into me producing that
um documentary with Kendrick or about
Kendrick and my homies called noisy
bompton and that then also had Vice vers
doing all of my videos then I had Fool's
Gold you know what I'm saying so that
was like kind of the push that pushed me
into like
all right I'm gonna take music serious
all the way you know what I'm saying